You're going to write the code to make the create
conference method, Creat and Save Conference Entities. But first I
want to point out how Creating Conference Entities is different
in a way than creating profile entities. For profile entities
we specifically use the unique user ID as the ID
for the identity key. For conferences though, we really don't
care what the key is. So we're going to let
App Engine allocate it for us. So here's the code
to let apengent allocate the key. You used
the factory.allocateId method, and in the simplest case
you just provide the entity class. So that
would be raspy conference profile whatever. So for
example, to allocate an ID to a conference
entity, you specify the key type and conference.
And you specify conference.class. But this isn't quite
right actually, though. One more thing we need
to do, is to take account of the fact that
the conference has a parent. Which is a profile entity of
the user who created it. So when you want to allocate
an ID to an entity that has a parent when you
call the allocate ID method. You need to specify the
parentKey as the first argument. So here's the code you need
to write to allocate an ID to a conference entity. You
need to specify the profile key for the ancestor and specify
the conference class. Another thing to mention is
that you've already learned how to save an entity
by calling ofy.save. But in this case, when you
save your conferences, you also need to save the
profile entity. You can just use the entities function,
IES, the pluralized version, and specify the list of
comma separated entities to save. You should have already
copied the skeleton version of the create conference method
into the conference API class. But if you haven't, go ahead
and do it now. You see that it's full of to dos.
You're going to go ahead and implement each of these to dos. First
of all, you need to get the user ID of the logged
in user. Then you're going to get the key of the user's profile.
Then you're going to allocate a key for the conference. And don't forget
the conference has a parent so you need to take that into
consideration when allocating the ID for the key. You're going to get
the ID for the conference entity. Then you actually
need to see if the profile entity corresponding to the
profile, that's the parent of the conference actually exists. If
it does get it out of the datastore, if it
doesn't go ahead and create a new one using the
default values for the profile properties. And then finally, you
actually create the conference. Then you need to save both
the conference and the profile entities, and return the profile.
The reason you need to save both the conference and
the profile entities. Is even though if you've got the
existing profile out of the data store, you haven't made
any changes to it. If the profile didn't already exist, you
will have created a new one, so you will need
to save it. So, go ahead and fill in the ToDos
in createConference. You already copied over the skeleton version of
it, and now you can write the code in the ToDos.
When you've implemented createConference. You can run your app
on local host. And then go ahead and create a
conference or two. And you can use API's explorer
or you can use the create conference page in the
WebUI. Then check you conference entities in the data
store viewer in the admin console. To make sure that
they go created as you expected. Now at this
point you actually can use the create a conference page.
In the WebUI for the app because when you submit
this form, it sends a call to the create conference function.
And you've actually implemented that now. So using this form should
let you create conferences. And it's kind of a nice, easy
thing to do. What you need to do is specify the
name, and all the other values will default. However, at this
point you can't use the show conferences to check that the
conference got created. Because you haven't yet implemented the function that
provides the behavior of the show Conference page. So, no
matter whether you create a conference in the APIs Explorer,
or the create conference page in the WebUI. You'll need
to use the data store view in the Admin Console,
to check that the conference got created. After you've created
some conferences. Go ahead and look at them in the
Datastore view of the Admin Console, and see if you
can figure out which properties are indexed. Check all that apply.